would you not agree with that I wouldn't
disagree with that he's also agreeing
with the Quran we're getting there guys
he's going to be become a Muslim
today defend against a rapid spread of
microplasma pneumonia AKA white lung
disease using black resins pagit packed
with immune boosting properties pagit
has been scientifically proven to
promote resp paraty Health aiding in
oxygen absorption while also making the
body infection resistant strengthen your
family's immune system ahead of the new
outbreak this winter don't forget to use
my discount code Ali dawa for 15% off
enjoy all right alikum guys as you guys
know it's Christmas and I came across
Santa Claus yeah Santa how you been not
too bad thank you and I hope that all's
well with you how you doing my name is
Ali right what's your name nice to meet
you Alie my name is Ed Ed Ed yeah nice
to meet you Ed
uhhuh you're looking solid well
hopefully you don't mind me asking how
old are you well well you can ask but
you won't get an answer 55 well maximum
that's a good guess
maximum okay so what are you doing today
uh just moing around you know I often
come here here to Speaker's Corner uh to
hear what people are saying and so on
and to meet people to get interaction
know what's going on in the world around
you good okay interesting so you're in
this outfit yeah is it just Christmas
season I it will has to be obviously
yeah yeah it's it's just a bit of fun do
you get like kids taking pictures with
you oh yeah I mean not just kids but you
might have seen around here people is
that is that your purpose today just to
come and maybe take pictures with the
kids and just yeah yeah I mean it's a
it's a joyous thing really you know it
creates um of fun for everybody you know
so Santa I mean the word on the street
is is Santa Claus an atheist is he a
does he believe in God what's what tell
us what's your belief well I certainly
would think that Santa CL any any Santa
CL would believe in God I think it's
based as you you may know on St Nicholas
yes I think he was from Turkey if I'm
not mistak believe so yeah I'm from
Turkey oh right there you are maybe
Santa Claus is my great great Grandad
well who knows yeah well so I think
that's what it originates from and I
guess he must have been a guy who was
yeah yeah giving out pres to children
and things like that it must have um you
know exactly but you as the other Santa
Claus yeah what's your belief do you
believe in god oh absolutely yeah okay
are you are you a Christian um
well I I I'm loathed to um label myself
if you know what I mean okay um but
certainly I believe in God there's no
question about that okay um there are
these various stories and you I'm sure
you'll not be unfamiliar here you've got
people like Christians Muslims and a few
Jews as well and then all say
I'm right no no you're right and it goes
on for you know every week okay so
you've got to you you know it's hard to
know which stories are true which
stories are not true okay so let me tell
you as a Muslim our perspective sure and
then we can decide what is your belief
system yeah for example you believe in
God yeah when did you start believing in
God has it been always since you're a
child is it something you came to know
have you ever been an Atheist no I've
always um had the belief that there is a
God simply
because it would it would be irrational
not to because everything that we see
around us is created uh in in in
intricate design and as we will all know
that if we uh if we take some sand or
whatever throw it on the floor it will
scatter into nothing maybe if we get
that same sand and we can mold it into a
shape of an animal and we can present
something but we had to have an
intelligent thought to make that happen
the sand wouldn't form itself into like
a rabbit of its own
accord Ed you're a very intelligent man
it's very simple it's very intelligent
tell the truth many people yes sister
you speaking the truth and you've got
intelligence and it's simple I've spoken
to here to atheists who will come and
tell me that the Universe came from
nothing or it was a chance and to me
it's Preposterous actually to me it's an
intelligent and for you to come and just
say simply what you said is as Muslims
we 100% % agree with that so now do you
believe God is a man do you believe he's
in the creation what's your thought Pro
process of God what do you think God is
do you believe he can be a man well I
would be inclined to think number one
why would he be a man a man is part of
reproduction thank you yeah see my point
so and also I would reason that if God
were to be a man yeah he is lacking
something because I'm something I'm a
man but I don't have the attributes of a
woman so a woman has qualities that I
don't have exactly surely God would have
all qualities God would have lack for no
quality so I don't think he would again
like labeling I don't think God would
label himself this or that I mean I
think
probably
people get the uh idea that God is a man
because because they think that well you
know the masculine side of the world is
it dominates and gets things done and
think that that must be what God is you
know but okay look you're getting more
intelligent as you're speaking I have to
ad I admire that you know why because
you're speaking from reason and
rationality and logic and as Muslims we
believe that every person is born a
Muslim do you know why we say that
because of the stuff you just uttered
why because nobody had to come and tell
you that God is a not a man like I don't
need to come here and tell you by the
way Ed God is not a man you be like well
duh of course I know that or by the way
Ed there is no God you be like of course
or if I said there is God you're going
to say of course there is God what
you're doing is we call the fitra in
Islam so what we call that is called the
F what the fitra means is you are
innately programmed to acknowledge God
exist to acknowledge he is one to
acknowledge he is not the creation but
rather the Creator the stuff that you
just said to me is things a Muslim says
Ed are you a secret Muslim tell me tell
me tell me who knows so Ed Jokes Aside
you are uttering the words a Muslim
would say sure God there is God that
exists good you're not an atheist
anymore God is not a man he is unlike us
this is the definition that we give to
God Almighty sure like I'll recite a
verse in the Quran for you have you
heard the Quran before yeah okay I'll
recite it for you yeah so Allah says in
the
Quran say he God is
one
self-sufficient he does not beget nor is
he begotten and there is nothing like
him yes would you not agree with that I
wouldn't disagree with that he's also
agreeing with the Quran we're getting
there guys he's going to be become a
Muslim today I'm joking now the point is
this though yes our perception of God is
that we believe God has attributes we
believe God is the all knowing he's the
most powerful he's the all wise he has a
will that he will the universe and us to
come be now what God Almighty wants as
Muslims from us is what that you have a
relationship with him that you have a
connection with him because we in this
world will be lost so is there anything
about Islam that you don't know because
you already believe in the fundament
like the fundamental which is who God is
would you accept that God has to be all
knowing yeah all powerful absolutely all
wise yeah good good so there's certain
things that you believe in now is there
anything you don't know about Islam that
you had a question mark about well um
like I say there are so
many things in stories people put one
perspective and other side put oh that's
wrong this is the other perspective it's
very hard
um to really yeah I mean you will be you
will appreciate the questions yes uh
will say that um you know Jesus is and I
know that you you regard Jesus as a
prophet he's a prophet Mighty Prophet
but Christians say that Jesus is
actually the Son of God exactly or God
or yeah well effectively sort of you
know exactly God coming down as in
exactly but you as a person who's not a
Christian or a Muslim logically does
that make sense logic from from from
from from one perspective you could
argue that it doesn't make sense from
another perspective you can argue that
it does make sense if you are prepared
to accept these steps that you'll be
presenting but that requires Faith yes
now putting Faith aside and using logic
and rationality you said God cannot be a
man why because you used your
rationality you didn't use Faith well I
I can't say that God can't be a man but
logically it wouldn't I'm sure I'm sure
God could be whatever God wants to be so
if God wants to be a man I can't say you
know okay good what we say is God in his
Essence and nature sure for example can
God
lie well
umri the only way I can answer that is
um surely God could do what God whatever
wants to do okay we say God does
whatever befits his majesty for example
can we say God concas to exist can God
die well I suppose only by God's Own
will could that happen I don't know okay
so we say he can't die because if he
dies then that will be against his
nature because he's the ever living so
what we say is God cannot lie because
he's lying is a something that is not uh
righteous it's not it's not it's not
something attribute of God that's why we
say God will never be a man and cannot
be a man this doesn't limit God it
actually shows his majesty and who he is
now have you read the Quran
before no more really than
little touch is here and there in the in
I gave him
one
I here and there but but that would
apply the same with the Bible I haven't
read the Bible little touches here and
there but with the Bible um more I hear
things so I'll hear and and and what
have done through growing up as a child
you know you'll hear stories and so or
sayings you know um I mean I a good
thing from the from the Bible I can say
you know I can tell you you probably
aware in the fact that um I think that
um uh Jesus I think said that you know
on the last day or whatever God will
turn to you and so uh you know you did
these bad things you did this and you
did
that and you know you you did these
things to me yeah and people will say no
God I I didn't do these things to you
and God will say to you whenever you did
these things to sorry whenever you think
do these things to anyone you did it to
me oh yeah if you visit a sick person
God talking about the Hadith of the
Prophet mammed PE be upon him he said
that um when I was not well you didn't
visit me and he said oh God you are the
he so you will never be unwell so he's
talking about a person who my servant
was ill and yes of course it's very
important yeah now I don't want to hold
you that much I want to end on this I've
got the Quran on my phone sure can you
maybe just do this like on a random
chapter and a random verse and may let's
see if there's a message in the Quran
for you so I'm going to go
to that inshah give me a second sorry
there we go so I want you to just pick a
random chapter just scroll and pick a
random
verse up yeah sorry sorry just just just
like that just yeah sorry yeah yep and
okay and then pick a verse one any
random any random okay let's see what
verse that is yeah okay so this is Surah
T
yeah okay Allah says in the Quran by the
Mount of T and by the book
written on the unrolled scroll and by
the populated house
Al and by the roof raised high and by
the Sea flared up with fire the
punishment of your lord is sure to fall
there is nothing to push it back the day
when the sky will tremble and and a
horrible trembling and the mountains
will move about a terrible movement so
woe to those day who reject the true
Faith which is Islam who are indulged in
vain talk playing with truth the day
they will be pursued be pushed to the
fire forcefully and it will be said to
them this is the fire you used to deny
is it there is it then magic or do you
not see enter it now whether you endure
it patiently or impatiently it is all
the same for you you are merily rewarded
for all what you used to do of course
the God-fearing will be in Gardens of
bliss enjoying what their lord would
have given to them and their lord would
have served them with it uh with and and
their Lord will have saved them from the
punishment of hell yeah it will be said
to them eat drink pleasantly because of
what you used to do now this is talking
about the people of Hellfire and the
people of paradise we want to enter
Paradise we want you to enter Paradise
as well and we say that that could only
happen with our relationship with God
Almighty so can you maybe when you go
home today
why don't you call out to God I did this
about 13 years ago I I came to Islam 10
years ago 13 years ago I was embarking
on my journey of finding the true Faith
right you you you were brought up in
Islam No oh you w I was not my dad is
like an atheist I so yeah so to me I
prayed to God and said God whatever is
the truth guide me to it I found Islam
not only does the Quran preserved hasn't
been changed there are many miracles in
it historical Miracles linguistic
miracles the prophecies so I would just
ask you pray to God and ask him and say
God I believe you're there please guide
me to the truth because in the Quran is
talking about the people of the fire who
denied the Hellfire you must accept that
if God exists there must be a reason he
put us here on because there has to be a
purpose why would God just put us here
and leave us on our own he must
communicate with us he wants good for us
so therefore I want to inshallah see you
in Paradise so I would say when you get
home just do a prayer and saying my God
if you are there please guide me and
you've already been given a Quran and
that's it if you have any other
questions for me anything else that's
very good advice You' just given me
there I appreciate I will take that take
that please thank you you're a sincere
Maness man and I ask God Almighty to
guide you and myself thank you it was a
pleasure you're a lovely person and
gentleman Santa Claus it's been a
pleasure and Merry Christmas to
everybody thank you very much thank you
take you thank you thank you very much
take care I mean that's it guys uh it
was very interesting speaking to Santa
Claus I've been looking for him for the
past 15 years I finally found him you
know uh but anyways brother sisters may
Allah subhana tala guide him um to Islam
he seems like a very nice person and
Allah subhana will guide those who have
good heart inshah till next time from
speak